somebody who's had uh the joy of getting
to know giannis over the years from
doing some great interviews through her
coverage at espn covering the nba is our
friend cassidy hubbard who joins the
show
right now cassidy i would imagine uh you
had a smile ear to ear last night
watching your friend
giannis get his first nba championship
you know i just had a smile listening to
you um
you know talk about kobe and just uh
like the
there's been a lot of kobe talk
obviously throughout these playoffs and
a lot of it's centered around devin
booker because of the the legendary
tattoo he got
and the the conversation the two had
um you know after they played each other
but
you can't forget that kobe publicly
you know um basically
to use your words inspired giannis told
him
go win mvp and then when he did he said
now go win a championship um kobe saw
greatness in giannis um i
probably before a lot of people did
and um it's just you know interesting
that you mentioned kobe and just
thinking about that connection
with um with giannis and just
what we walked last last night was was
inspiring you know listening to him
talk about his upbringing i know
a lot of people under you know know his
story and
the anecdote of him selling trinkets on
the street of greece
to help you know support his family
not picking up a basketball until age 13
to now um you know these last
three seasons alone mvp regular season
mvp regular season and then one of the
most
iconic finals performances in nba
history
and i don't think that's an
overstatement no definitely not it might
even be
an understatement cassidy it's it's the
fact that it's not
it's one of it might be the best finals
performance we've ever seen game six or
even the
the entire series take me back though to
your first
interactions with giannis i remember you
interviewing him at all-star game in
in new orleans and that was a big moment
for him
uh walk me through your earliest
memories of getting to interact with him
there was actually there's actually like
a gif out there of me interviewing him
telling him like pointing to the mic
because he didn't really
know how to talk into a mic i mean i'm
sure he did but it was just like a
reminder
like he wasn't used to doing media at
that point i think he was just
like i may have been his second or third
year in the league
um but yeah i mean his
his growth i think is well documented on
on the court like early on before you
know he became an mvp in this league
the big story around him is wow like
he his drastic improvement from year to
year not just in his size which alone
is like i mean he like
blew up into like a ninja turtle um but
like
it's uh it's just also how comfortable
he is um in the joy you said of
of of the game like you talk about uh
the iconic performances like he he he
has
three final moments um
on the court you could say he he he has
he of course he has the the block
he has the alley-oop and then he has the
50 piece nugget in the in the closeout
game
but i also feel like his
message on the how he views
you know the right competitive mindset
um before game five in the practice
media availability where he broke down
talking about your ego i'm talking about
your past being your ego
and talking about your future being your
pride and focusing on your present being
your
humility there's like there's so much
in that and it was so believable
uh of that's how he lives his life and
why he was
why he's in this position right now as
um
you know two-time mvp and now finals mvp
and the champion
um and bringing that championship to
the team he was drafted by cassidy
hubbard joins the show espn nba reporter
host of course of hoop streams ben
lyons filling in for rich on the rich
eisen show and something i loved about
this year's nba finals cassidy is that
you saw fans out there you saw the deer
district you saw people
uh out in phoenix losing their minds for
the sun's first time in the finals since
93
for phoenix as someone who's been in
that arena covering the bucks
what's the energy like there out in
milwaukee now that giannis has
brought them a title i mean
what a scene last night right then that
was insane
65 000 people like i you know on my show
um at the beginning of the series we
were talking about the dear district
kind of like
hating on on the name i feel like it
should be like the deer garden
or you know bucks wild or really you
know i've heard people say it should be
called gianna's garden
because you know that that was built
that was the house that uh that giannis
built that was the
that was the scene that giannis built um
but that the five perform is a is a
beautiful
arena um and i actually just heard the
story
that you know um when you know
the buck ownership took over the nba
basically said that if you know they
didn't build a new stadium that
um you know the the team could be moved
to a different to a different city and
you know
that so much that that team
that franchise has gone through and that
that scene last night
was incredible i mean the seas of people
and the fact that they are able to
clinch it
at home for those fans um
you know i don't think uh giannis or or
the bucks could have uh drawn it up any
better
love seeing monty williams after the
game go into the bucks locker room
congratulate the team and what a class
dude and just an inspiring guy in his
own right
uh how do you think this loss impacts
phoenix moving forward
devin booker and the status of chris
paul next year
who has a player option on his contract
well just a little note i mean molly
danger's reported that actually giannis
um was the one who to talk to to monty
after that and invited him into the um
into the room um and of course you know
uh monty graciously
um you know as he as he does
was was fantastic in that moment i mean
you couldn't help but hurt for him
his the emotion he poured out after that
game
um you could feel how much he wanted it
for his guys um this was
you know this there was a lot of heart
that was put into that
to that run uh i you know i think devin
booker has proved
he's a star um deandre yayton
you know he he's the growth that he
showed throughout these playoffs um
i mean he's going to learn so much you
you forget like devin booker
you know he has such a stone cold
face that he keeps on but he's just 24
years old
you know 22 and you know i think chris
paul has such a connection with monty
who knows what he's gonna he's gonna do
but you know those two guys um that the
future is really bright now
there's a lot of competition throughout
this league
um but you know that experience
last night and throughout these playoffs
is only going to make them better i mean
i i looked at there was that clip going
around on nba twitter of um
devon looking at the the scene as the
confetti coming coming down and him just
saying damn
um if you don't think that's gonna
motivate him then you know you haven't
been paying attention to
the type of guy and player he is no well
said and it reminded me again another
kobe connection
with devin booker kobe walking off the
floor in the boston garden after game
six in 2008 and the celtics destroyed
the lakers and
he took that moment as motivation to go
on to win back-to-back titles so
i i thought i thought that as well when
i saw devin booker last night
um what's the ripple effect around the
league you think cassidy uh
regarding giannis comments after the
game about super teams and about getting
it done
in milwaukee and building something from
the ground up do you think
james harden was sitting on in a
bungalow in monte carlo
just stewing right now do you think
kevin durant across the across the world
in tokyo getting ready for the olympics
overlooking
the city skyline just pondering what he
what his life could have been like had
he stayed how do you think
those comments will impact the culture
of the nba
i mean i think it's going to be fuel
look this is like
these are all ultra competitive guys who
all want to win
um and you know they see a guy in
giannis who
who has basically all the accolades that
you can get in the last three years
what other people want and um
whether that's the jealousy or
competitive fire
like that that should motivate those
guys
um and you know giannis
whether or not you want to focus on the
super team he he did do it the hard way
he did you know promise to take
this team that he was drafted by
um to a championship level
and you know i like
that and he and he did it the year after
signing his extension i sat down with
him
after he signed this extension i asked
him what
what why sign now when you can
essentially just
wait out the year and um you know get
wined and dined and get the same
offer um next year and because i don't
want the distractions like
not for me but for my teammates you know
i want to win
here and i don't want to give up a year
of my crime
um in order to do that and you know
that should that that should motivate uh
those guys what is it gonna do i don't
know maybe they'll have some
conversations like
over you know dinner like being like
does this dude really just call us
out but at the same time they i mean
it's uh
they're gonna have to swallow that pill
because you know he
he did it as lebron james tweeted he
earned that
he earned it cassidy hubbard joins the
show
nba reporter of course the host of hoop
streams
and does a great job covering the nba
for espn
uh i always love seeing you out there on
the sidelines talking to the players
being in the stadiums being in the
arenas what's it like
now to sort of be back in the mix after
the this this unprecedented time in in
our life and and
the the bubble experience that that was
so challenging for so many people both
on the floor and who cover the game of
basketball
just to have that experience this year
in arenas and being out and about what
did it mean to you
ben this is a hell of a season this was
a um i mean this was an exhausting
season not for me
i mean yes for me but that's not what's
important but
for the league i mean the turnaround
just the day-to-day the
like there were basically no practices
even like the little detail of um
having to test in the mornings uh
ruining
or messing up with with a lot of these
players
routines which you know is um something
these guys kind of live by um this is
this was a
arduous season and it was a war of
attrition
and if people want to nitpick at the
injuries
and you know um you know
this guy didn't have to face this player
or this player
like just how we said the bubble um
you know and and that experience should
have been counted as a
as a title and a half this season
i mean like what these players had to
overcome
um in order to do their jobs
and perform at the highest level like i
just don't think that that can be
understated i mean it's incredible that
we had that scene last night with all of
those fans whereas like
my first game was actually in milwaukee
where i was in a little
like plastic box by myself
you know in the stands covering the game
with no fans there
just back in december what a year this
has been
um you know just in just looking at you
know
the nba in in in uh you know in a box
here
um not the entire world in general what
a year
it's been that's a bigger larger
conversation but
as far as you know what the nba overcame
and and and and this this conversation
around chris paul
and if not winning this title is not
winning this title is gonna hurt his
legacy
i've always said i i've stayed true to
saying that
you know i don't think that his legacy
is going to be hurt i think
when you look back at what he's done
last year with the bubble and this year
with just the expedited season be able
to pull this off
um he he will be you know thought of as
one of the greatest leaders that
this nba has seen um and i think he also
proved that
to bringing the sun's team um to the nba
finals
and you know two games away from from
winning their first title but
you know what could have been cassidy
hubbard joins the show nba reporter for
espn ben lyons in for rich on the rich
eisen show
now it's party time for giannis and the
bucks chris middleton and jew holiday
have to get on a plane maybe with devin
booker to go to japan for the olympics
which will be an awkward flight
i'm sure but giannis gets to go to
greece and go on a tour and
and take the larry o'brien back to his
home country it's gonna be an epic
summer
in mykonos with those guys the whole
family gonna do it big
obviously um talk to me just sort of
about
giannis's uh you know relationship with
his brothers and and obviously they're
celebrating this moment with him
uh thanasis of course as a teammate but
just you know that dynamic between those
guys and what does this mean
what does giannis's success mean to the
family and to them
you saw it last night in the trophy
ceremony when he was
kind of reminded hey you
and two of your brothers are champions
you know i i do feel like
i feel awful for thanasis because um
you know i i just i think we were robbed
of some incredible
cutaways of of him celebrating his
brother he's one of his
biggest cheerleaders is also you know
just a
like a big beating heart for
for that team um you know
it's unfortunate it's also a microcosm
what the season was like
um so many so many
just bumps in the road and
they are so close i mean he was the
first person that he you know
called as soon as he walked off the
court me you know we all saw
the ig live of him saying i'm gonna come
into your hotel room and celebrate with
you and he's like no no no
you know don't come but like they
they're so tight
him and his three other brothers and um
his mom of course
and you know this the i started kind of
tearing up when i was listening to him
talk about
just the sacrifices that his parents
made um
and you know what what has how his
mother supported him
and you know i've had conversations with
him about just how much his father meant
to him and
to you know lose his father at the
beginning essentially of this this nba
journey like before he won his mvps and
you know obviously won this title i mean
his dad
was his everything and as you know he
writes on his shoes and he writes
um you know in his uh bios on a social
media he is his dad's legacy
and you know you could really feel like
he he felt like he was he made his
family proud and um his family is
everything to him
you know there's these criticisms of
like why don't
whatever whatever you want to well
credence you want to give that but
what you know is he accepted by other
nba players and
i my answer to that is that look he
didn't he didn't grow up playing aau
with a lot of these guys like a lot of
the american players that you know
um have done great growing up here in
the states he
he's close with his his family you know
keeps a
tight crew and um and they're everything
to him and i think that's helped him
stay focused on
you know what's important getting better
and
you know finding the joy in the moment
that's kind of what your family does for
you
they keep you grounded and they um you
know help you
be the best version of yourself will you
help us make a better show today cassidy
by taking some time we really appreciate
it i always look at you as like the
howard coselle to ali with giannis you
guys have had so many interviews
over the years and you know him and his
family so well so we appreciate you
sharing your insight but i got to be
honest the real reason i wanted to have
you on is because you're maybe the only
other person
today who's as excited for bobby portis
as i am because i know he was a member
of your chicago bulls
and a member of my new york knicks so we
both have a lot of love for bobby this
morning
crazy eyes and you know what he actually
kind of likes that nickname so i don't
even feel bad calling him that oh he
owned it last night and he was terrific
i mean you could not be less
phased than he was when chris was
starting to come at him
he he was a fantastic story
i mean him and pj tucker i'm so happy
for pj tucker
um you know just i i asked him
you know what he was most proud of he's
36 years old we talk about this like
fountain of youth with chris paul and
lebron james and pj tucker like
sacrifices his body on a nightly basis
and he joins the bucks mid-season
um which is hard in itself and you know
he
he put his body on the line every night
you may not like if you're not paying
attention
to the game just looking at the box
score you're like what is he doing but
he he did all the like intangibles
and um he actually beat like all of his
former teammates uh
in route to winning the title so shout
out pj tucker not just the sneaker king
and natural nba champion now
i'm so glad you gave him some love i
always pay attention to who's holding
the ball at the end of the series and i
think it was fitting it was pj tucker
cassidy thank you so much for taking
some time it's great to catch up
always my friend thank you for having me
cassidy hubbard
espn nba reporter host of hoop streams
and the howard cosell to giannis i mean
she's interviewed that guy so many times
right all-star weekends and like she
said he remembers fondly of him
not even really knowing how to use the
microphone or being comfortable in those
settings then you see him holding court
last night
with the larry o'brien the finals mvp
he's kissing him both he's cracking
jokes he's showing love to his family
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here